nuestra meta es calcular la solubilidad
del hidróxido de cobre 2 y nos dan la
constante de producto de solubilidad kps
que es igual a 2.2 por 10 a la menos 20
a 25 grados celsius conceptualizamos
este problema primero y digamos que
tenemos algo de hidróxido de cobre 2 que
es azul
digamos que agregamos un poco de
hidróxido de cobre 2 en un vaso de
precipitado que contiene agua
este es un compuesto iónico poco soluble
no todo lo que pongamos en el vaso se
disolverá digamos que sólo una pequeña
porción de esto se disuelve tomaré mi
borrador aquí y quitaré un poco de
sólido de aquí arriba digamos que esa
pequeña porción se convirtió en guiones
coaliciones tenemos en solución
el cobre 2 nos dice que tenemos iones de
cobre 2 más en la solución
dos más y luego también tienes iones de
hidróxido en solución o h - tenemos
iones de hidróxido en solución también
eventualmente alcanzamos el equilibrio
alcanzamos el equilibrio de solubilidad
donde la proporción de disolución es
igual a la proporción de precipitación
así que continuamos escribiendo eso cuál
es la fórmula química para el hidróxido
de cobre 2 podemos usar este pequeño y
simple truco de aquí cruzar tus cargas
para obtener la siguiente fórmula
química
si uno en paréntesis
h y 12 aquí ese es nuestro sólido y
también tenemos nuestros iones
dos más nuestros ángeles en solución
también tenemos los iones de hidróxido
en solución
- necesitamos balancear esto así que
necesitamos un 2 en el guión de
hidróxido y todo lo demás aquí tendrá un
1 hagamos una tabla ice tenemos nuestra
concentración inicial nuestro cambio y
luego finalmente nuestra concentración
en equilibrio antes de que esa pequeña
porción de hidróxido de cobre 2 se
disuelva esa pequeña cantidad que borre
antes no tenemos nada para la
concentración de nuestros iones en
solución
esa es la concentración inicial de
nuestros iones
ahora pensemos en la pequeña cantidad de
hidróxido de cobre 2 el sólido que se
disolvió digamos que x es igual a la
concentración de hidróxido de cobre 2
que se disolvió vamos a perder la
que diremos es x
de tus proporciones molares por cada
molde hidróxido de cobre 2 que se
disuelve obtenemos un moldean iones de
cobre dos más en solución si estamos
perdiendo x de la concentración de
hidróxido de cobre 2 vamos a ganar x
para la concentración de iones d
tengo dos más en solución y para iones
de hidróxido por cada molde hidróxido de
cobre 2 que se disuelve obtenemos dos
moles de iones de hidróxido en lugar de
x sería 2x ganaremos 2x para la
concentración de ión de hidróxido en
equilibrio las concentraciones de
equilibrio de nuestros guiones serán x
para el cobre dos más y 2x para el
hidróxido escribamos nuestra expresión
de equilibrio kps es igual a vemos
nuestros productos
tenemos pseudos más ponemos
concentración de
y dos más y elevamos la concentración al
poder del coeficiente y aquí nuestro
coeficiente es 1 el vamos es toda la
primera potencia luego nuestro otro
producto de aquí será el guión de
hidróxido o h - y elevamos esa
concentración al poder de un coeficiente
que en este caso es dos necesitamos
escribir un 2 aquí nuevamente dejamos
este sonido puro fuera de nuestra
expresión de equilibrio bien evaluamos
para acá ps nos dieron la constante de
producto de solubilidad es de 2.2 por 10
a la menos 20 evaluamos eso esto es
igual a 2.2 por 10 a la menos 20 y esto
es igual a la concentración de iones de
cobre dos más en equilibrio que
agregamos eso esto es x a la primera
potencia por la concentración de iones
de hidróxido en equilibrio elevado a la
segunda potencia
esto sería 2x y luego tenemos que
elevarlo al cuadrado aquí y aquí es
donde algunos estudiantes se confunden
un poco porque dicen que estás
duplicando la concentración aquí y luego
la eleva al cuadrado
estás haciendo lo mismo dos veces pero
recuerda estas son dos cosas diferentes
este 2x es por las proporciones molares
y lo elevamos a la potencia del
coeficiente porque eso es lo que haces
en una expresión de equilibrio esas son
dos cosas diferentes no estamos haciendo
lo mismo dos veces ahora sigamos con
nuestra álgebra en el lado derecho
tenemos x
por 4x al cuadrado y eso es igual a 4x
al cubo esto es igual a 2.2 por 10 a la
menos 20 necesitamos dividir eso entre 4
tenemos que dividir 2.2 por 10 a la
menos 20 entre 4 puedes hacer eso en tu
cabeza o en la calculadora 2.2 x
al menos 20 dividimos eso entre 4 y
obtenemos 5.5 por ea la menos 21 tenemos
que 5.5 por 10 a la menos 21 es igual a
x al cubo
para obtener el valor de x tenemos que
obtener la raíz cúbica de 5.5 por 10 a
la menos 21 y desafortunadamente en esta
calculadora es un poco más enredado que
en otras en otras calculadoras es muy
directo y fácil de hacer déjame
mostrarte cómo sacar la raíz cúbica de
algo en una de 85 calcularemos la raíz
cúbica así que pondremos un 3 aquí y una
manera de encontrar la función es ir a
la segunda función catálogo y
desplazarte hacia arriba hasta ver el
símbolo
no lo he visto
ahí está ese es el símbolo que queremos
estamos intentando obtener la raíz
cúbica de 5.5 por 10 a la menos 21 y eso
nos da la raíz cúbica que es igual a
continuemos redondeando eso a 1.8 por 10
a la menos 7x es igual a 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 7 y esta será la concentración las
unidades son volar esto será la
concentración de cobre dos más en
equilibrio
volvamos aquí arriba
es igual a la concentración de cobre dos
más en equilibrio y nota que también es
igual a la solubilidad molar de
hidróxido de cobre 2 esto es cuanto
hidróxido de cobre 2 disuelve x así que
encontramos la solubilidad molar del
hidróxido de cobre 2 la pregunta nos
pide la solubilidad por lo que quizá
quisieron referirse a la solubilidad
molar y en ese caso hemos acabado o
quizá se refieren a la solubilidad en
gramos por litro continuamos haciendo
eso ahora esto es igual a la solubilidad
molar y esta es la xo
con unidades de moles por litros
qué tal si quieren gramos por litro
necesitarás tener la masa molar del
hidróxido de cobre 2 puedes sacar ese
dato de tu tabla periódica el hidróxido
de cobre 2 tiene una masa molar de 97.57
gramos sobre mol
nuestra respuesta aquí para solubilidad
molar
esto será moles por litro si quieren la
solubilidad en gramos por litro
veamos nuestras unidades y pensemos en
lo que tendríamos que hacer tenemos 1.8
por 10 a la menos siete moles sobre
litros
si vemos la masa molar si quieres saber
los gramos sobre litros lo único que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar la
solubilidad molar por la masa molar
porque las unidades para la masa molar
són gramos / moles y si multiplicamos
los moles se cancelan y acabamos con
gramos sobre litros continuamos haciendo
esos cálculos redondeamos esto a 1.8 por
10 a la menos 7
esa es la solubilidad molar para obtener
la solubilidad en gramos por litro si
multiplicamos eso por 97.57 que es la
masa molar del hidróxido de cobre 2 y
obtenemos si redondeamos
1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 eso es igual a
1.8 por 10 al menos 5 y éstos serán
gramos sobre litros
esta es la solubilidad en un litro de
solución puede solo disolver 1.8 por 10
a la menos 5 gramos por lo que el
hidróxido de cobre 2 no es muy soluble
después de todo esta es la manera de
saber la solubilidad si te dan la
constante de producto de solubilidad k
de s